That feeling when you meet a new dog and it's
all like and I’m all YAAAAAS LOVE MEEEE!
Is that gross?
Greetings canine connoisseurs, dog devotees,
puppy pundits!!
Okay, I'll stop.
I'm Julian, this is DNews.
Welcome.
Although cats are the most popular pet in
the US, outnumbering dogs by around 8 million,
there are about 12 million more households
with dogs-- presumably because crazy cat ladies.
At least one DNews episode shows that humans
who live with animals are affected by the
animal's microbiome.
But what about when those pups try and lick
your face?
GROSS.
Or, is it?
What exactly should I be feeling?
I'm so conflicted.
First, there is a myth out there that dog’s
mouths are cleaner than a human's.
This is not true.
Both humans and dogs mouths contain bacteria,
lots of it.
And there's really no way to directly compare,
because while they are both mouths, they're
completely different environments!
Studies of the bacteria of dogs mouths have
found hundreds of species of bacteria, with
"significant" differences to human mouths.
Only 16 percent of dog oral microbiota overlaps
with humans.
Another study in the Archives of Oral Biology,
says there are definitely harmful pathogens
in your pup's face-hole!
A separate study in PlosOne from 2015, found
that oral-to-oral transfers of bacteria from
dogs to owners can cause gingivitis and periodontal
disease!
P. gulae, for example, can cause inflamed
gums and even tooth loss...it’s super rare
in humans, but common in dogs, and 16 percent
of owners had it!
There's even some bacteria in dogs mouths
which are antibiotic resistant, meaning if
it were to spread to humans, we would have
trouble treating it.
On top of all THAT, if you have a cut in your
mouth, or some bleeding gums from basic gingivitis,
bacteria from your dog’s tongue could enter
that open wound, and spread infections deeper
into your body.
We do have some natural defenses, though.
Both human and dog saliva have antibacterial
properties.
They're basic, but play a part in wound-licking.
That DOESN'T mean you should let your pet
lick your wound though.
*Case studies have found infections from another
mouth bacteria in animals called Pasteurella
can result.
A pasteurella infection can be treated with
antibiotics, but can also be dangerous as
it opens the way for more serious infections.
So, the thing is, yes, face licking can be
gross… but there's not actually a ton of
danger from infectious bacteria.
They ARE there, so being skeezed-out at the
idea of swapping saliva with a dog is probably
warranted.
But sources are quick to say, both mouths
contain tons of bacteria.
Plus, PET LOVERS: INFECTION GOES BOTH WAYS.
You don't want to infect your dog with YOUR
dirty mouth do you?!
To be honest, you're more likely to catch
an infection by swapping saliva with another
human than with a dog, but just to be safe…
you know… the more you know the better.
You do you, but think about where you put
your mouth, and if you're a kid or elderly,
you're even more susceptible to infection.
In the end the Centers for Disease Control
recommends anytime you ever come in contact
with any dog you wash your hands afterward.
Maybe splash a little soapy water on your
face if you’re getting puppy kisses too.
TT Newsletter push
TestTube now has a newsletter!
Get a weekly round-up of our most popular
videos across all our shows at TestTube.com/fwd
Dogs are starting to show up everywhere these
days, even in bars and restaurants… should
you be worried when you're sharing a pint
with a poodle?
Brunch with a boxer?
Snacks with a shit-zu?
Trace answers your worries in this video.
What do you think?
Do you let dogs lick your face?
Share ice cream with you?